loja my name be Ryan right so there's
this video game trailer out for a video
game that I saw the title for I was like
I have to watch this it is a course
called god Zilla ELISA is not wearing
makeup today she looks just yep
God like daring I know you know
sometimes you shouldn't be so daring
it's like it sounds like a bad thing
like hide my face you kind of just I
don't know I get this like Marie vibe
from you now I just kinda only want to
punch you in the face or something you
know I love I just I just totally like
how does the one who totally encourage
you to just be in the video anyway no I
think you look better without makeup I
think Marie looks better over that
makeup to worry rocks it without makeup
great there's a really good job without
me yeah and you do - I think you look
better without it
thank you no seriously yeah I never this
is this is probably a very very very
rare thing that you will never ever see
again yeah it's cool cuz well I
masturbate to you know imagine without
makeup it's gonna be awesome
even better thank you anyway let's watch
this trailer Oh Nico
this is kind of cheesy does it really
look like it is crap
do you play as Godzilla
I don't know how because we're past
PlayStation 3 well it said it was coming
out this year for PlayStation 3 which is
not current so now I don't know if it's
real I don't think so
you sure it was on a game trailer site
it doesn't look real I don't there's
something about it just doesn't seem
right to me all right whatever they said
that video is posted five days ago
PlayStation three anymore this looks
like a really bad yeah why do I want to
play is like a really slow Godzilla just
wrecking the city the whole thing I
think if it really is real which I'm
still doubting they should have given us
a little more to work with a little more
of a feast for the eyes which they
denied us that looks like something
someone cooked up like in the matter of
an hour that's like some computer yeah
thing that they cooked up or like this
would be a fun video game maybe I can
pitch this it looks wrong it does look
wrong oh so wrong and that's what turns
me on about it kind of like us getting
together there just want to be right I
think if you could play as Godzilla it
would be a little bit more fun I think
you do play as Godzilla that would be
good it still looks like it would be
kind of boring though yeah but you know
what boring games can sometimes be good
okay take Slenderman mm-hmm and the
pages thing you're going around in the
dark looking for pieces of paper you're
going around in the dark looking for
pieces of paper totally boring concept
but somehow managed to be like one of
the best things from Fright Fest it may
not look good doesn't mean it won't be
good I just feel like they should have
kicked it up a little bit more there is
not a single part of me that really
cares to play this game I kind of you
I guess cuz Godzilla but if I didn't
know anything about gods what and I
should saw that I would be like I don't
know I still never saw it I never saw
Godzilla when it came out I really want
to do he missed out it did hopefully you
know what movie night well rent it yeah
we'll rent a movie I already seen that
sounds
yeah that's true we've been sitting here
watching friends reruns and he's
complaining about seeing a movie
he's already Z it's different though
you've seen friends too
so I know but I don't love Godzilla that
much yeah friends are special yeah yeah
I have too much friends or Godzilla Oh
what friends anyway guys if you're new
to the channel sorry the channel you can
subscribe and Alyssa has a channel which
it's Alyssa be [ __ ] wild crazy I told
a story yesterday she did she told the
story something about an airport that's
one hostage held hostage at an airport
SFO now that's a rough story dude they
like tortured you for like three
straight days give you probably any food
you have to pee in a bucket and poop in
the bucket it was just it's horrible and
they did you just left the bucket in the
room with you and just smelled just the
you know like no it was horrible and you
just heard the sounds of people getting
tortured outside all day you didn't see
the light of day for three straight days
just a dark room yep anyway that's her
fun story she told on her Channel yeah
man everybody good I don't like people
thank you that then they hate me like yo
I'm gonna get some shoutouts real fast
Victor now 67 he said so way for my
shoutout man lol no well you said still
waited for my shot man lol you know when
someone says that they're like lol but
they're really not [ __ ] laughing out
loud like did we actually give him a
shout-out like a little while ago cuz I
recognize that name I don't think we did
it I know this guy pretty well
yeah certain names the ones we go over
that's good to keep it track good to
keep that track man Vic no you better
not be conning us you [ __ ]
don't be [ __ ] with us I'll have your
balls you hear me
your balls you know if I was a criminal
like a kingpin of like a mafia I would
collect people's balls after I kill them
I feel like that would be a really hard
thing to collect well first I would get
my menace snippet their balls
while they're alive gotcha and then get
a little case like a little trophy case
display and it's all the people who have
had killed my first turn off their spell
cast reading but it's that chemical they
would be floating in water no it you
need a certain chemical like it's
escaping me why look how about we figure
it out when we get there okay okay
anyway big now yeah I'll snip off your
balls moved on to better things
Dion Ben NOLA please give me a shout-out
okay all right shut up
yeah you really gave me something to
work with here man yeah like okay you
just want me to say her name they could
do that but now I got come up with
material this is great this is great I'm
horrible at thinking on the spot you
know you need you need like a little
notebook and crayons yeah crayons why
because crayons crayon cranes friends
crayons Korea knows any Koreans to write
your messages
it's cranes cranes cranes Kranz why do
you think the Oh silent it's friggin
great on shut you're not saying the oh
you're going crazy
you totally missing yeah I know it's
like our channels are part of the same
universe r34 lxg Ryan you better give me
a shout-out you sexy son of a [ __ ] well
r34 lxg that's a hard name to shout out
you son of a [ __ ] you know son of a
[ __ ] can really be taking a lot of
different ways you know you'd be like
come here these son of a [ __ ] or that
someone pisses you off you son of a
[ __ ] or like something goes wrong son
of a [ __ ] so many different
connotations
yeah weird really the English language
is a very strange thing is it now yeah
why why do you say that why why you
feeling like America get out of here I'm
just saying like taking balls resistance
balls take that and run with scissors
sorry balls running with scissors
I'm tired is the best excuse for
anything
everything everything if you're like
feeling down hey you're right you have
just tired you say something stupid I'm
just tired you murder someone I was
tired I didn't even run that guy over
with my car I get out and stab him a few
times he does weird things when he's
tired yeah I don't know why I made such
a dark joke I'm just tired
oh there's more we got more video to
film of this one alright now we're gonna
keep the camera rolling do it see what
else we can pop out of our noggin Wow
oh I gotta get that we can't feel him
anymore